[Musique]
je veux juste envoyer des prières à la
à ceux qui ont été perdus la nuit dernière, je suis
honnêtement juste dévasté
[Musique]
nous avons travaillé en étroite collaboration avec tout le monde
pour essayer d'arriver à la liste du bas
quoi  a causé la montée subite, nous ne le savons pas, mais
nous le découvrirons et y a-t-il quelque chose de
criminel,
nous avons entendu des rumeurs de personnes s'injectant
de la drogue à certaines personnes
les gens sur
le terrain subissent une sorte d'
arrêt cardiaque ou un certain type d'
épisode médical
et nous avons donc
immédiatement commencé à faire de la RCR et à déplacer
les gens à ce moment-là
[Musique]
je voyais deux corps allongés
juste derrière moi
et euh
tout le temps j'étais juste  pensant qu'ils
s'étaient évanouis
, puis une fois que l'agent de sécurité était
juste à côté de moi, il parlait à un autre
agent de sécurité en disant qu'il n'avait pas
de pouls, c'est à ce moment-là que j'étais
en état de choc complet
[Musique]
plus de 300
patients ont été traités au  à l'
hôpital de campagne qui était sorti qui a été
installé ici à cet endroit
[Musique]
mon frère était allongé sur le sol
ils scandaient pour arrêter l'événement
personne n'a arrêté cet événement
producteurs de musique
tout le mondela sécurité
était là
j'ai perdu mon frère parce que  de cela
[Musique]
nous avons un rapport d'un
agent de sécurité selon le personnel médical
qui était sorti et l'a soigné la nuit dernière
qu'il tendait la main pour
retenir ou attraper un citoyen et qu'il s'est senti une
piqûre dans le
cou quand il a été examiné  il a
perdu connaissance, ils lui
ont administré du narcan,
il a été réanimé
et le personnel médical a remarqué une piqûre
qui ressemblait à
une piqûre que vous auriez si quelqu'un
essayait de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette injection n'est pas quelque chose que vous vous
attendriez à faire après être allé à  un
festival
allant à un mémorial pour les personnes qui
sont mortes dans ces festivals
vous